اعلنت شرطه مكافحه الارهاب البريطانيه
انها قررت تحويل تركيزها في مواجهه
الارهاب لمواجهه التهديدات من دول معاديه
كروسيا والصين وايران وقال رئيس وحده
مكافحه الارهاب في لندن مات جاكس انه تم
تحويل التركيز لمواجهه محاولات دول اجنبيه
لترهيب الناس والتورط في مؤامرات قتل وخطف
في بريطانيا واضاف المسؤول البريطاني انه
يجب لعب دور في انفاذ القانون ضد الدول
المعاديه وهو امر غير مسبوق مشيرا الى ان
ايران نفذت ما لا يقل عن 15 محاوله
لاختطاف او حتى قتل مواطنين بريطانيين او
افراد مقيمين في المملكه المتحده تعتبرهم
طهران تهديدا وقال المسؤول الامني
البريطاني ايضا ان الشرطه تجري تحقيقات في
مزاعم بان الصين ادارت العام الماضي مراكز
شرطه في مدن رئيسيه في العالم بما في ذلك
نيويورك ونفت الصين هذه الاتهامات